all right this is really important this
is so important i'm even going to take
my sharpie out for this
i am really glad to have some time today
to do a deep dive
on videos from a focus group with trump
supporters this was hosted on monday
night two days before the inauguration
of joe biden
we've been talking about what do we do
now about 75 million
trumpists how do we deprogram and it's
really
an important insight into the mind of
the trump voter and what we're up
against for these next two and four
years
this is a focus group done by frank
luntz a longtime republican focus group
guy
who has been anti-trump for some time
and if we are to understand how to
de-program trumpists
we have to understand how they ended up
believing the things they believe
and this is the perfect window through
which to do that so let's get right in
we're going to have lots of analysis of
this but
let's get right into the first clip and
let me know whether you find this type
of segment useful
raise your hands if you think that
donald trump actually won the election
if all the votes are counted accurately
who thinks he won it
all but one of you okay denise
where's the number one source for news
for you
i love watching fox news i love
listening to the news because i drive a
lot for a living and i
right now by the way i'm living in
washington dc i'm staying with my
daughter these past two weeks and it's a
nightmare here it's a nightmare
but um i listened to the news i listened
to the news and what i just heard
recently that they're comparing us to
the kkk
one of the newscasters the any
republican it's
it's disgusting okay so denise
thinks trump won she likes to listen to
fox news
washington is a nightmare and she heard
that she as a trump supporter is being
equated to the kkk
because she voted for trump so notice
that there's a total lack of awareness
that the reason washington on monday was
a dystopian nightmare
with troops on every corner is because
of other trumpists
who violently rioted on january 6th and
she says
i've been watching fox news which has
not
actually made the connection that trump
incited
the pro-trump mob that did the writing
so it's really important to see how her
beliefs are directly informed
by how fox did or but maybe better said
did not cover the riots the link
between what you watch and what you
believe is very very clear this is not
trivial
let's continue randy where do you get
your news from what do you watch
i used to watch fox news up until the
election um so now i kind of just
looking online
i was getting it from twitter but i
deleted my twitter account once
they censored the president so
now i don't even really know where to
get my news because i don't know what's
true and what's not i don't know what to
believe from anywhere
just going back right so there's a lot
there
that's just 27 seconds but listen to how
much
telling information is is released there
she used to watch
fox but not anymore increasingly common
among trumpists
she used to get news on twitter until
they censored trump
so notice that even where she used to
get her news
that's not news fox news isn't news
twitter itself isn't news although there
can be news articles posted to twitter
but i would be interested in seeing who
these folks are following on twitter so
it's a lack of media literacy for years
i've been pointing out
rather than just arguing with people
about the facts if we establish a
foundation of media literacy
you insulate people from even falling
prey to a lot of this stuff this is a
perfect example this is exactly what
i've been talking about for a decade
then a guy yells that she should be
getting her news from breitbart and
newsmax another self parody let's
continue
wendy where do you get your news from
newsmax
uh formerly from fox occasionally i'll
watch the five
um top radio
so another example of a former fox
viewer
and she says sometimes i will watch the
five
on fox news again the five
is an opinion show on fox which she says
she's getting
news from this is a case study
in everything i've been saying about
media literacy for the last decade on
the show
now frank luntz asks why so many of them
have stopped watching fox news take a
listen
who here has stopped watching clock
since the election
half and half charles why did you stop
watching fox
i started i stopped watching fox a
couple of years back
i just i just saw them sliding further
and further and further to the left and
i
and i i have cnn for that i have um
msnbc for that i don't i don't need fox
to go to the left
so i get it my news from breitbart
newsmax
meredith why'd you stop watching fox oh
me
i didn't um so much and when you say
news i know where i get my opinions but
news
i you know unless i see it with my own
eyes anymore i don't believe anything
it's pretty terrible actually i don't
know
how do you know the election was stolen
if you don't believe anything
i don't know it was stolen i know that
that when somebody wins an election at 4
00 am and people stop voting that's just
not how we do things
fox is too left for the first guy he
went to breitbart
and newsmax meredith doesn't believe
anything anymore that's an example of
when skepticism goes too far
healthy skepticism is good uh
unquenchable skepticism
leads to you believing nothing and it's
completely unproductive so
this is really instructive because our
beliefs about these people
they might seem like satirical
caricatures
but it's literally what they're saying
and what they believe
now if you think that this is useful i
do want to hear from you if you think
these these
to me this is endlessly instructive and
i hope it is for the audience
so now frank luntz gets into beliefs
about a so-called stolen election
and now the the focus group participants
start getting
more agitated that's all we ever wanted
was an investigation we were told to
move along
nothing happening here just keep moving
don't
look don't ask questions yeah it's
absolutely
we look and we ask questions when we see
a guy who campaigned from his damn
basement he had 12 people show up at his
rallies gets 80 million votes come on
yeah it doesn't make sense so i'm
investigating and i look at numbers all
day
and i i when i went to bed at night
pennsylvania had
we were we were up and then when i woke
up
900 000 votes all of a sudden went to
biden and he won by what like three
percent in pennsylvania
it doesn't make sense like if you look
at the numbers
they don't make sense and so then i
listened to the hearings
all the hearings i listened to all
single people talking about it
something happened congress is not doing
their due diligence to investigate this
they don't want to investigate it right
because it'll take forever
it'll take forever no it'll take their
power
to take forever it'll take their power
and and then when they played when they
played a game like they were going to do
something
they weren't going to do anything they
it's like for the next election
we can come to only one conclusion from
listening to that
and unfortunately it's that the country
is in
real true deep serious trouble like
really really deep remember uh talking
about
hearings those were legally irrelevant
hearings
where no one was under oath none of
their claims were verified period
and that's why she thinks it was rigged
and it keeps going and they start
getting each other more and more wound
up
but we got to live with the results of
this one that was stolen right
right why should we vote tell me why
thank you i mean look at georgia exactly
the same process was used in georgia and
whoopty do surprise wookie new surprise
the deputy
with hr1 her first bill of the new
congress
is to cement into law the very things
that they use to steal this election
yep and now they've got the majority to
pass it they're going to change the
rules and keep power
that's what i fear for about my children
is that this is not the america that we
that we grew up in because they're going
to change the rules just like adolf
hitler did
just like fidel castro just like
you shot us it's gonna happen are you
sure you really want to compare
joe biden and the democrats with adolf
hitler you should
it's not the methodology the methodology
absolutely
technology's there so there as predicted
they think not only was
georgia stolen from trump it was also
stolen
in january from kelly lefler and david
perdue
it's not even a possibility for most of
these folks that maybe trump lost and
lefler lost
and purdue lost and then of course he
raises a comparison between 2021
democrats and adolf hitler
and others in the focus group like it
others in the focus group say yes
that's a correct comparison so this this
is really stunning stuff
and if you're wondering how do you
deprogram that i don't have the answer
the the point here is for us to
understand how deep the programming is
it's horrific
then the topic is how do you feel about
the january 6th
trump riots are you proud of what they
did at the capitol
i am sympathetic to what they did at the
capitol i am absolutely sympathetic
because
i feel like i have nowhere to go after
this last election
what am i supposed to do i can't vote
them out
they're going to refuse to be voted out
no term limits no balanced budget
they're going to refuse to be voted
i'm out i think the congressman should
be
i think the congressman should be pulled
out and each of them face a tribunal and
face punishment for what they how they
betrayed our country
over all these years every one of them
should have to face the american people
for what they've done people agree with
frank
i'm curious how many people i agree with
frank these guys that should have a
reckoning coming
no that frank not two friends i want to
make it clear
this is agreeing with frank from florida
not me
yeah i know he's coming from i do he he
wants a reckoning he wants to know why
these people have betrayed us
and he wants them to stand up there and
say yeah i betrayed you for money or
power or a chinese spy or whoever it is
in that one i actually am unsure
who they're referring to in terms of
having a tribunal for members of
congress
to me if you say david who needs to face
consequences
it's the republicans that supported the
trump election coup attempts
but i have a sense that those trumpists
are talking about democrats facing a
tribunal i don't know
and in this next clip they say more
about the allegedly
fraudulent nature of the election but
then there's a really interesting guy
here
jim from michigan who doesn't think the
election was stolen
and quit the republican party so listen
to him this is a really important moment
of clarity
and and the reckoning is normally an
election but we don't have that anymore
no don't have that anymore powerless you
know i
um you're listening to all this and um
i left the republican party about
about three weeks ago because of what i
saw at the capitol
i was embarrassed um i was embarrassed
for the president
i voted for him twice i had my lawn
signs out i had my flag up
i'm embarrassed i'm embarrassed because
look at kovid
how that's totally out of control right
now you don't hear from this man anymore
he's pence has got to go around and what
he did to vice president pence
and threw him under the bus i will never
i see that the other way around jim
no i disagree that's dependent friends
could not do anything
under the constitution but not do
anything pence
did what he had to do pence had two
months
pence had two months before he came out
and gave that letter he had two months
to say
what he thought and he he betrayed us
just like the democrats and the
republicans have
pence had two months and he remained
silent
so that's jim from michigan jim says
trump failed on kovid
he abandoned his own vice president and
jim is embarrassed
so here's the takeaway that's a focus
group with 12
trump voters 11 of them just 48 hours
not even 36 hours before the
inauguration of joe biden
are completely disconnected from reality
and they seem to be beyond reach 11 of
those 12 people
i don't even know how we reach them one
of the 12
jim from michigan actually saw what
happened and saw things for what they
are
and said i can't be a part of this this
is wrong and he sort of seems to have
deprogrammed himself
that's really rare and the fact that one
out of 12 people did that is very
important
that may be the proportion that we're
working with in terms of what portion of
these people
can reasonably be deprogrammed and as
you can imagine 1 out of 12 is not
enough
it's not enough to fix the problems that
we have in this country it's not a great
percentage
so hopefully this is really good work
actually by frank luntz
hopefully this helps us to understand
the issue
and the more we understand it the more
of a shot we have it fixing it and we'll
be talking more in the coming weeks
about
how it can maybe be fixed but as you can
see
that's an uphill battle that's a real
uphill battle we'll have more on this
on our instagram page at davidpakmanshow
on instagram while you're there
follow me on instagram at david.pakman
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today
is helix sleep i sleep on a helix
mattress
at home i absolutely love it and that's
why
i reached out to them about sponsoring
the david pakman show
buying a mattress in the past was always
a huge guessing game for me
i didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but
helix has a sleep quiz on their website
you tell them your body type your
sleeping position
your back pain issues you might have and
their
tool matched me with a mattress that is
perfect for me
it's cool enough at night it's the right
firmness
i generally just do way better sleeping
these days because of the mattress helix
was awarded
number one best overall mattress for the
last two years
by both gq and wired magazine it is well
deserved i can tell you firsthand
every helix mattress comes with a 10
year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights
and they will even come pick it up at
your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video